damit werden aber hollywood wasser hat
vorjahr
murat ernsthaft herzlich willkommen zum
jura 25 minuten oder manchmal auch
länger
heute gibt's ein cooles rezept meine
frau ist sich da der gewinn ist auch
nicht da und ich habe ein höchsten
rezept zu machen mal was veganes ich
weiß jetzt alle schockiert ich bin
selber kein veganer und das ist
vielleicht auch cool warum muss ja auch
nicht belehren warum jemand im vegan ist
oder warum man nicht vegan ist aber ich
habe keinen freund und mit einer schon
öfters gemacht und zwar ist es der
vulkan wolke vom vulkan ist hier also
okay wir machen das ganz cool ist und
zwar machen
das traditionelle musik machen ihr
traditionelles ecken und zwar thomas
egalisieren
aber ich kann ja jetzt schon sagen ich
weiß nicht funktionieren es ist keine
alternative als ist nicht irgendwas
gesagt okay ich mach's vegan und
schmeckt halten mich so gut aber ich
sage nein ist was ganz ganz neues was
richtig genial ist und bevor ich mich
hier um kopf und kragen redet zeigen
jetzt mal die zutaten wir haben ja
butter durch margarine ersetzt sieht aus
wie butter ist aber margarine
aber es ist jetzt nicht die böse
margarine und zwar ist sie mit rapsöl
und kokosfett und sie kommt ich kenne
die marke sei aber nicht meine fragt
sich ein paar mal benutzt das ist keine
produktplatzierung ich wollte nur sagen
dass sie aus schleswig holstein kommen
und zwar liebe grüße nach
schleswig-holstein wenn ihr aus
schleswig holstein kommt den daumen nach
oben natürlich regional 150 gramm zucker
tonkabohne extrakt das ganz ganz cooles
was neues ist ein extrakt ist es zu 100
prozent natürlich und auch vegan habe
ich recht man kann ja schmeckt richtig
hammermäßig so genau aber ist kein ohne
nein das kann genau eine prise salz 450
gramm mehl und zwar tief 405 dann haben
wir hier ein 15 teelöffel backpulver
dann haben wir milch durch milch ersetzt
ich auch kein problem das heißt wir
haben das ding nicht legalisiert ganz
ganz einfach dann fangen wir an
ja genau das war schon mal anfangen ich
zeige dass wolken und zwar bei
hauenhorst die butter 1
zum kneten das ist ein ganz normaler
beliebtheit wichtig zu sagen und was ich
euch auch noch sagen wollte
bitte hier einmischt feines mehl ich
könnte auch ein 550 nehmen nimmt aber
nicht das ganze was ich sehe ja aus dem
globus immer benutzt warum wir das zu
ferrari kurz rücken und zwar schock
gekriegt so ganz kurz einfach reinmachen
man kann ja und hierfür vermerk westen
fest datei ist benutzt sie bitte hier
zum nachhören ganz wichtig wie gesagt
jetzt haben wir ein guter drin
jetzt kommt nur noch die 150 gramm
zugang ist ein ganz normaler zucker wie
möglich übertreiben wenn man was anderes
nehmen können zucker sagt aber doch noch
irgendwie nochmal schmecken hab ich
recht so jetzt immer dieses tonkabohnen
extrakt und zwar immer einen teelöffel
sagt da kam ich zu viel machen das geht
gar nicht so
dann war noch salz rein perfekt und
jetzt lasst muss ganz am anfang bei
niedriger stufe runter genau muss immer
hier den hebel zuerst und dann runter
und langsam auf jeden fall machen wir
jetzt weiter genau kurz eine minute
ruhen lassen und nachdem es in rückeroth
haben nehmen wir das mehl bei de-mail
ist es ganz ganz wichtig volkan dass wir
zuerst ist backpulver reim machen aber
ein gemacht folgen des vulkan beim
backen beim ganz einfach jetzt nicht das
ganze mail auf einen schlag rein sondern
langsam genau jetzt immer das mal hier
und jetzt wo man das coole ist ja und
jetzt geht es langsam rein und es ist
ganz ganz wichtig dass man das langsam
einmal jetzt schon gefallen kann schon
ein bisschen die mandeln milch dazugeben
ja jetzt kann auch bis in die stufe nach
oben drehen kann auch drei gehen ja
stimmen dass die zuschauer erst mal
sehen
es ist richtig ein richtiger teigklumpen
wo sie ist nicht mehr einzelne sagen das
ist richtig schön ein homogener geworden
so ausgesehen
es reicht auch schon das hat dass ich
mich schwergetan jetzt ist alles in
ordnung jetzt kann es nicht mehr viele
drum machen oder wie auch immer
eigentlich ist ja meine hände gewaschen
übrigens das raus ist es ganz wichtig
kann man die spülmaschine machen doch
kann man wirklich ja ja man kann es
wirklich machen aber nur ideen hier weil
er ist genau aber ich sage das immer
macht es nicht es ist zweifellos der
wegzaubern
ok jetzt zum teil und zwar wenn wir
jetzt einfach dass genau das backblech
kulisch weißlicher hat das wollten die
hitze konto namen richtig genau dann
immer hier natürlich auch für die umwelt
permanent manipuliert richtig cool
so und jetzt haben das gemacht jetzt mit
dem bug rahmen der zimmer jetzt auf
ideal größe aus aufs maximum okay volkan
und jetzt machen folgen das jetzt immer
denkt den den teig einfach so an drücken
mit der hand ok kannst nachteil sein
ehrlich bist du nicht so ein bäcker muss
ehrlich sagen ja auch nicht so ich auch
nicht ich mag gruppen und ich komme vom
kopf aber ich auch nicht ich gar nicht
wenn ich sage ich muss auch wenn ich
meine frau zu mit sicherheit haben angst
dass der teig nicht weiter teig muss
richtig dünn sein
ich meine mit geht nicht mehr groß auf
obwohl jetzt backpulver drin ist und
betriebsmittel drin ist wahnsinn was
verpackt gegründet ich habs gerade voll
denke ich bin voll dabei und es mich das
wirklich schön flach andrücken und
gucken dass er wirklich die ganze
backblech ab
[Musik]
nokia bleibt der schweiz kein schwein
und wohlig muslim bin okay so auf jeden
fall am anfang nach der teig reichliche
auswahl was ist da wieder verbockt aber
ist echt so ihr müsst es wirklich
wirklich schön andrücken der kann ruhig
flach sein der teig jetzt haben wir
schon mal den boden gemacht worden
und jetzt mal erfolgen dass beide
möglich was ganz ganz wichtiges und zwar
ohne gabel das thema gepäck war unter
monatlich an den teig war okay warum
eigentlich luft vielleicht damit
gleichmäßiger wagt richtig genau habe
ich doch gesagt so das heißt es auch
bekannt dass du hast auch von meinem
wissen hast was mitbekommen da die
löcher rein damit er gleichmäßiger
aufgeht
ein thema das jetzt im kühlschrank bei
ungefähr sechs grad
mit neuen kollegen auf sechs grad haben
einstellen könnten hat halt pech gehabt
oder uns war einfach wie lange eine
viertelstunde stunde 20 minuten 1 zu
werden
ja also vulkan wolke acht grad platz im
kühlschrank schnell rein und wir haben
es macht zeigt euch die zutaten für die
so ist sagt und abfüllung das oder sag
mal und zwar nicht sein belag sondern
nur säcken belag genau und dafür zwei
zutaten letzten 200 gramm megane mutter
45 gramm wasser 150 gramm koks blüten
zucker was ich gemacht habe ist
folgendes ich habe den zucker
ausgetauscht durch kokos blüten zucker
und was passiert dadurch ja es wird
teurer und zwar teurer aber chorus
blüten zucker ist es besondere richtig
es ist gesund einige solist nicht ja das
sagen es ist aber besser eigentlich 250
gramm vegane haselmann haselnüsse
folgendes weder zeit habt keinen
gefallen tut noch anrösten könnt ihr
einfach in die pfanne reinmacht die
pfanne heiß aber es tröstet ihn es noch
an gibt noch mal einen extrem geniales
auch immer so
dann haben wir hier ein thema wie
vanille dann haben wir hier
gemahlene mandeln oder gehackt der
handel mangeln und da haben wir hier
noch komisch 100 gramm
und jetzt werden wir das alles zusammen
in einer schale
coole idee jetzt werden manche von euch
gleich schockiert sein was ich mache und
zwar so jetzt wir haben die bruttomarge
alle rein
diese schale ist induktions geeignet
macht auch 3 genau das macht die
batterien schön bisschen schmelzen
ich sage mal gute aber rein rechtlich
ist es eine marine aber keine böse
margarine dann nehmen wir hier den
kokons blüten zu kommen wir auch dazu
schön sagt rhein
das soll jetzt machen wir hier die 45
gramm wasser das ist egal
dann bist du sicher ja so und jetzt tut
mir einfach hier nämlich auf 5 wie
schnell das jetzt geht und leider könnt
ihr das allerdings kein berufs fernsehen
weil das wir in kokons bilden zucker
riecht ist so genial wirklich überrascht
ich glaube bestimmtem als bonbons gern
bestimmt mit kokos blutzucker gemacht
oder wenn es nicht gemacht hat wir haben
eine marke gemacht dass bitburg nur mal
kurz früheren produktplatzierung und
zwar ist das transformer und es war der
transport der kann haken hackfleisch
allem drum und dran kann auch vegan sein
wenn du nur nüsse rein machst das war
jetzt auch gott sei dank
diesmal wies kapiert und so kam was
jetzt macht es hier auf
geniale da
perfekt jetzt aber das hier gemacht
jetzt noch der rest dreimal kam auch die
gehackten man rein und kokosflocken auch
noch ein so jetzt haben wir ja im web
kamera tonkabohnen drin
ein extrakt und die füllung machen wir
jetzt noch ein bisschen vanille rey und
zwar auch ein teelöffel kämen zwei kann
es einige zu vier einmal so jetzt
demokratisch schön zusammenrühren zu
einer homogenen masse blogger der vulkan
hat damals schon gesagt hat der hat
jahrelang in dubai gelebt und in london
spricht perfekt englisch und jetzt ist
echt der wahnsinn sagt an ihm können
sich vielen beispielen seit zwei jahren
ist in deutschland über 33 jahren auf
ein jahr warst du dir ein ja nicht
offiziell einfach eingereist ohne
papiere
ja also das seit zwei jahren offiziell
ja schon hier genau geschlossen kann hat
deutsch gelernt ich übrigens auch und
gerade zuschauer ist kannst du
wahrscheinlich auch deutsch ich gerade
lese sondern manchmal drei sprachen
richtig schon umrühren
das können was eigentlich auch schon vom
herd nehmen und die schüssel ist jetzt
wahr aber nicht tragen ist genau so wie
gesagt die man sich verlassen kann so
ein bisschen abkühlen mehr schwachsinnig
in kaltenbrunn zunehmend ein heißes zeug
drauf zu tun haben uns abkühlt jetzt war
noch kurz den boden der schon ziemlich
abgekühlt
genau so und jetzt kommt der nächste
streich und zwar streich im wahrsten
sinne des wortes und zwar machen wir
jetzt auf den mürbeteig machen wir jetzt
der schicht auf mit marmelade und zwar
ist es ein aprikosen marillen gemischt
ja und zwar kein spaß das ist aus
unserem eigenen garten hat es allen
gemacht der ist auch vegan
pektin gemacht so der schmutter wolke
jetzt drauf mit dieser palette die ist
keine demokratie
das ist erst mal verstehen das ist die
ist so abgewinkelt sich abgewinkelt das
ist perfekt ich kann es jetzt am rand
entlang zum rausschmiss
ich habe gerade werden die kamera aus
hamburger kurz diskutiert mit einigen
bin ich mir nicht mehr sicher ob dies
jetzt nehmen marillen
marmelade oder aprikosen oder mirabellen
marmelade ist ist egal
aber seid da einfach kreativ - was ihr
zuhause haben aber normalerweise nach
dem großen marmelade
[Musik]
ich hab ja noch so einen riesen löffel
gefragt wozu malwerkzeug hat wer braucht
so ein mist sie ist es und dann wählt
sagt neben und jetzt braucht es
plötzlich waste water for interest kann
man noch an so halt essen ich liebe
meine frau mama auf jamie oliver neben
dass dinge einfach hier und machen das
hier drauf und dann schön fest andrücken
volkan aber gleichmäßig ich war bei mir
schon die so ist drin normalerweise
musst du jetzt nicht mehr rein ich mache
das für dich weil du bist mein veganer
freund thomas balkans war ich mache ist
so wertvoll für mich dass ich mit dir
weh generation war ganz schön hinten so
dass bei 180 grad
ungefähr 30 bis 40 minuten in den
backend ich sag 30 bis 40 warum weil
jeder backofen in anderen bank genau er
hat wahrscheinlich vielleicht daheim
nicht unbedingt die serie achternbusch
die meisten haben es wahrscheinlich
kohleproduktion jemals gesehen habe
waren saison okay
so jetzt haben wir es abkühlen lassen
ganz wichtig sei jetzt wirklich wenn es
abgekühlt ist es ist noch leicht warm
bei uns bei mir jahr drehen und deswegen
mit kurz abkühlen lassen und das jetzt
in streifen schneiden
am besten funktioniert natürlich mit
einem brotmesser zu
[Musik]
weil wir es in reichen geschnitten habt
noch mal kurz im kühlschrank dass wir
nachher die schokolade das wahlweise
nächste schokolade darüber machen dass
es kalt ist richtig so aber schon jetzt
aber die mussten geschnitten und ich
möchte halt die originalen noch einen
kokon rücken haben
genau daher kommt es auch nur genau und
da jetzt mal hier und hier haben wir
noch kuvertüre und zwar 300 gramm
profiteure habe ich programm wenn es
auch einfach zu rechnen ist wenn wir die
methode machen die zeige ich jetzt schon
zum 15 mal aber es gab ein problem ist
immer neue zuschauer dabei so jetzt
nämlich vier von sechs stunden
das sind zwei drittel war diesmal das
kapiert und in den transporter sitzt
die sache so das ist so was sagt man
ihnen der konditoren branche sagt man es
ist die dritte hand
das macht pro kopf drüber in den toffees
wasser drin und jetzt erhitzt sich das
wasser
da gehe ich gleich auf duisburger zoo
jetzt kann ich die meisten nehmen und
kann sie darüber legen
jetzt da ist es schon geschmolzen
und jetzt diese methode jetzt eben auch
den restlichen restliche ein drittel und
die dumme hier rein
der rest noch rein und mich nun die
schokolade wo ich jetzt doch reinmache
bringt genau die warme schokolade genau
auf temperatur 28 bis 30 grad wollte
jetzt immer durch geben sagt ja dass da
wirklich keine flocken mehr drin sind
richtig schön so jetzt haben unsere
schokolade auch schon fertig perfekt so
und jetzt haben wir unsere musical story
war es laut jetzt aber muss ecken geholt
aus dem kühlschrank und das ist ganz
cool volkan
jetzt kannst du zwei methoden machen
immer du gehst jetzt einfach hin und tus
mit jedes mal locker zu machen oder wie
man es auch die ganz normale art und
weise sorgen
und wenn ich richtig spaß gehabt auch
heute zum ersten mal neben gemacht und
dann auch das vegane ich bin total
schockiert
probiert es aus sind nussecken jetzt
werden vielleicht noch einholen der
natürlich auch probierten es noch ganz
kurz abkühlen lassen
man kommt sarah und die probiert mal
herzlichen applaus für zara zara ist
unsere fotografen mit der samira
zusammen sarah du bist veganerin und
jetzt ist so wir haben den ball nicht
haben veganen gemacht kennst du
eigentlich mal gedacht ok ok jetzt wird
es freuen wenn du mal die lustigen
probieren müssen wirklich ohne wir haben
auch vegane butter genommen oder vegane
margarine 1000 aus schleswig holstein
unglaublich also alle die ausschließlich
holstein kommen noch mal einen daumen
nach oben wenn nicht im herzen so lange
sarah ist wo wir ruhig genießen ein
bisschen muss nicht gleich sagen wir
könnten volkan übrigens auch folgen und
zwar bei instagram unterbett work der
ball kann mach da designs der läuft
durch den wald und immer wieder auf dem
weg findet baute etwas daraus
und auch der saar abfolge sarah wie
heißt du nochmal auf instagram okay
finde mein geben unterstrich plk sarah
unterstrich pkk sarah folgen weil sie
macht privat auch fotos auf jeden fall
jetzt zum thema mégane ehrlichen provinz
das liegt an getroffen sorry konsistent
was besonderes ich habe das vor den
trick raus du musst kokos blüten zu
nehmen ist und mal ziehen geschmack hat
richtig ohne witz hat uns gefreut wieder
als legales zu machen
komisch immer die veganen sachen
englischen immer nicht voll mit euch
helfen uns nicht hätte ich die anderen
und wenn ihr nicht vegan seite gehabt
so oder so kann man trotzdem essen kann
man trotzdem essen ist hast du mich
sagen ich keine alternative ist was
besonderes macht gut
[Musik]
das ist hammer gewesen ich ohne sparen
normalerweise müssen wir lügen nicht
aber diesmal ernst zeigt wie gut aber
das war
du bist auch immer bessere du wirst
immer besser balkan
ja wir sind zusammen besser ja ja ich
kriege keine
[Musik]